le temps passe mais les gens
sympathiques à sa cause sont toujours au
rendez-vous en macadam a jamais trouvé
la vraie justice se sont montré leur
appui à omar khadr il porte aussi ruban
orange la couleur de la tunique que
revêtait khadr à guantanamo où il a été
détenu après son arrestation en
afghanistan quand il était âgé de 15 ans
en 2010 il a plaidé coupable à cinq
chefs d'accusation de crimes de guerre
dont un en lien avec le meurtre d'un
soldat américain il a été condamné à une
peine d'emprisonnement de huit ans qu'il
purge maintenant au canada en course et
en présence de omar khadr souriant et
détendu que ses avocats sont venus
plaider sa cause ils réclament une
libération sous caution en attendant de
voir si les états unis vont accepter oui
ou non d'entendre son appel selon une
cour canadienne aurait le pouvoir de lui
accorder cette liberté
sorti de prison omar khadr poursuivrait
ses études cette petite université
chrétienne d'edmonton a déjà annoncé
qu'elle lui ouvrirait toutes grandes ses
portes de brest
selon la présidente de l'université il
s'agirait d'une bonne manière de
réintégrer cet ancien enfant soldat une
vision que tous ne partagent pas on va
pas ça d'un bon oeil vous savez monsieur
kader des accusations graves depuis des
années ottawa s'oppose à toute forme de
réduction de la peine à laquelle omar
khadr a été condamné selon les avocats
du fédéral une libération sous caution
violerait les ententes ottawa washington
ce qui est certain c'est tout ce dont
c'est la même des questions très
novatrice et les premières fois que les
tribunaux canadiens ont à se poser ces
questions-là cadart c'est le coq
complètement particuliers d'abord donc
je pense que les arguments valides des
deux côtés la cour du banc de la reine
de l'alberta va entendre demain encore
la demande de libération provisoire
d'omar khadr la juge a déjà affirmé
qu'elle allait prendre du temps avant de
rendre sa décision si raphaël bouvier
oakley radio canada edmonton